well according to the anti-choice right
if abortions are bad then adoption is
good and in fact you have all these
couples and people with pictures where
they say we will adopt your kids don't
abort we will adopt your kids so it's
all good right and abortion
increased adoption everybody's happy
well not so fast
a radical repugnant republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
is now saying that non-biological
parents are dangerous to children they
are dangerous to children well hold on
abortion's bad
but adoption is also bad that doesn't
make a lot of sense
but that's what she's saying
lgbtq nation reporting marjorie taylor
green calls non-biological parents a
danger to children
she doesn't like fake mom and fake dad
does she have a problem with adoptive
parents
now let's put aside for a second that
her buddy matt gates
is like really an adoptive parent to
that kid nelson i think his name is
maybe maybe that's a danger with matt
gates let's ignore that for a moment
um and see what she had to say on her
very strange podcast so let's talk about
children children are in the greatest
danger in america today
because tradition of guns right i mean
i'm sure she's going to say this there's
more school shootings than ever all
family values are being destroyed oh
oh
the idea that mom and dad together not
not fake mom and fake dad but biological
mom and biological dad
um
can raise their children together and do
what's right for their children um
raising them to be to be confident in
who they are their identity their
identity is they're they're a a child
you know made
by god right let's talk about children
um nothing increases the confidence of
kids than being told their parents are
fake
and not that good right i mean that'll
really set kids up for success so
the entire
point of this is
certainly homophobia and probably
transphobia as well so what marjorie is
really pointing to here is
gay parents where maybe one parent is
biologically related to the child and
one is not
um adoptive couples right just like a
gay couple
or a lesbian couple
um and i guess because she says
non-biological even heterosexual couples
i guess are a problem because if it's
not biological it's bad according to
marjory taylor green
certainly transgender parents of all
kinds i i can only imagine even a
biologically related transparent
marjorie taylor green would say is no
good stepmoms and stepdads certainly
must be bad based on this idea foster
parents probably also terrible and then
guardians and caretakers of all kinds
like when a kid dies or whatever that
that they're all dangerous they're all
extraordinarily dangerous so what do
they want
do they want kids to suffer no they want
moms to suffer that's really it i think
the kids suffering they're indifferent
to but it's the moms if i mean listen if
you have
uh
non-pro what do they call it
non-pro-creative sex
and there's a pregnancy
you've got to suffer as a parent that's
really important now there's two sides
to this stuff okay
there's the cartoonish nuts with their
podcasts like marjorie taylor green but
then there's the underlying policy ideas
that they want to push
and you know where this is going they
they're laying the groundwork they did
it they made it clear after roe v wade
was overturned by the supreme court
gay couples they don't want to be able
to legally adopt
they started with abortion
gay rights are on the chopping block
they're already talking about
overturning uh the decision that banned
bans on same-sex marriage effectively
legalizing effectively legalizing gay
marriage nationally there it's all on
the chopping block and meanwhile
consider the absurdity that they say
don't abort
will adopt your kids
well but actually
when when kids are with parents that
aren't biologically related that's bad
so is adoption good or bad is it worse
than abortion or better than abortion
they don't want people to have abortions
and now they don't want the wrong people
to abort
if only there was a way
to prevent unwanted pregnancy before it
even got to the point of a pregnancy
then we would have a solution oh we have
that and that that's also something that
they're against it's been widely studied
and when you go to them they
talk in circles they talk past you they
ignore they come up with well that's not
actually done the right way because we
know really good study done out of st
louis
you um divide
young people in particular
into groups where one group gets nothing
this is your control group
another group gets free access to
contraceptives
another group gets
access to comprehensive sex education
and then your fourth group gets both the
access to the contraceptives and
comprehensive sex education who do you
think has the fewest unwanted
pregnancies it's the last group
the group with the access to
contraceptives and the sex ed why don't
they want it because of their strict
father morality they have a belief that
okay fine maybe that would work to
reduce pregnancy but if you have
non-pro-creative sex particularly out of
wedlock as they love to say isn't that a
beautiful term you're locked wedlock
um
then you deserve it you deserve you
deserve to be forced to carry a
pregnancy to term that's fundamentally
their belief it's not about well
abortion adoption whatever no no no it's
about you gotta behave
the way they believe
jesus wants you to behave even if you
don't care about that particular
religion or any religion that's what
they want